what a friction to start out this is
friction
well what about chemistry between link
and joe because he does end up at her
door it's great anatomy so i feel like
we all sometimes play a little bit of
chess
with each other in relation right
we have so much to talk about starting
with the return of so many alumni kate
walsh is coming back what can you guys
tease about that
well first off she's amazing i didn't
did chris did you know that she was
coming back until you read the script
because i didn't know
no i saw yeah i saw it in the script and
then and then sorry at the zoom table
read and
yeah and he geeked out everyone freaked
out basically yeah fangirled a little
bit
yeah she's back and she's it's kind of
like she's never left because i feel
like her presence and scenes is that she
just kind of owns the hospital
i'm like oh my god it's addison i think
we can we can say that she's working on
a really amazing
case
that joe is desperate to get in on okay
so the return of addison maybe doesn't
mean more drama but more
scientific breakthroughs
i mean as it's always possible there's
drama
right
that's really anatomy it goes with the
territory yeah exactly camilla what
should we expect from joe this season
because she's adopted a baby she is
working towards becoming an ob gyn a
couple things are happening for her i
think that you see obviously she has her
new baby so she's dealing with being a
single
working mom and not having much help and
i think that that's really good for you
know
she's leaning on link for advice which
is you know her bestie for her advice on
how to do this um
and then
what you're gonna see that's kind of
funny is it like she's back to being an
intern
like she's back to square one
so she's doing skutt and things and so
i feel like that energy in the early
seasons of her you know being an intern
and making mistakes and kind of running
around like is back again for her so
it's been really fun to play so those
are things you'll see in the beginning
of the season okay so exciting stuff
chris for you what a heartbreaking
season finale because amelia did turn
down link's proposal
how does he kind of deal with the the
aftermath and the heartbreak
of that this season
yeah well yeah he definitely uh he he
definitely got turned down in a big way
um like he swung big like multiple times
for rings
multiple times posing
yeah yeah i mean you know i'm reading
the script going blink are you sure
you want to do this
uh but you know he swung big he got the
kids in there he got four rings he was
ready and uh you know she turned him
down spectacularly
and um and
it it it definitely threw him for a loop
because he started thinking about
different marriage differently in in
when he was living with amelia because
the rejection was was
uh was a lot so he's crawling back into
his hole and trying to recover meanwhile
he's co-parenting scout with amelia and
and and having to coexist with her in
that world and uh and it's there's a
little bit of friction a little bit of
friction to start out this is a lot of
friction
well what about chemistry between link
and joe because he does end up at her
door we know that they're longtime
friends
i would like to see
a possible romance there could that be
in the cards
i don't know we haven't seen the script
yet where that happens it's great
anatomy so i feel like we all sometimes
play a little bit of chess
with each other in relation right but
right now i feel like you know they're
just kind of leaning on each other right
now in in different ways i mean joe
definitely needs him
you know parent-wise and he and she is
helping him
through this breakup that's happened
just like he helped her with um
with alex so
i mean
right now that's sort of where they're
at with each other
link's kind of the support for the
parental aspect
yeah um of joe's life and she's kind of
the support for the romantic aspect of
his life and they're really feeling a
void in each other's lives at the moment
yeah
well all good relationships stem from a
friendship so my fingers are crossed
okay
uh the promo that was released showed
meredith on a mission after she of
course survived covid
how has that i guess near-death
experience
changed her
this season
i think that what's like her like eighth
near death experience i feel like i
think that it kind of
got nine lives
i think for sure i think that it's kind
of um
made her
focus more on what matters to her and
sort of tune out all these things that
don't necessarily matter in her life and
sort of streamlined her into thinking
more so about
future big decisions for herself it's
probably how i would put it it's true
she's cutting out some of the fat or the
bs yeah from her life and really and and
making important decisions for herself
okay
does that include romantically
uh
[Laughter]
in agreement with the lock and key
scenario all right fair i feel like
there's always speculation that
whatever season of grace we're on that
it's the last season yeah what do you
guys know
at this point no i just feel like we
should make like a blanket statement
like a recorded statement all of us that
we never know
right chris just know we don't even know
if it's the last season ourselves
no we have no idea we have no truly we
never literally your guess is as good as
ours it's wild to me that
you guys wouldn't know
what would there have to be a specific
time that they gave you to make a
decision about that or
would it just be a surprise if if it did
happen
i feel like
i feel like it would kind of be a
surprise i honestly i feel like we'd
find out like one hour before it hits
all the news that's what i feel like
because it would be such a huge secret
and such a big thing to release
that i think that we would find out
right before you guys find out is what i
honestly think
you would i would find out three days
after i went and then i would text you a
month later
that's how it would work
well that's hilarious i hope this isn't
the end because so many fun casting
um announcements were made for this
season peter gallagher is also joining
chris how is it to have a little bit of
a oc reunion you know i think without us
without spoiling anything i could say
that we haven't had any scenes together
yet i'm really hoping we do um
so uh so we haven't gotten to bump into
each other you know with with the
coveted protocols and all that stuff
they keep set really tight
so it's not like you're dropping in and
visiting and saying hi
but uh but i'm really hoping we get to
work together because it's great to see
him in the in the table reads and uh and
he's a sweetheart i i can't wait to uh
to work with him again if this is the
final season what other characters would
you guys like to see come back
one last time
while i was speaking to
capshaw yesterday i would love to see
arizona come back i i just adore her i
think she's the character's amazing
jessica's amazing i would love for her
to come back and work with joe you know
now that joe's ob so that would be
that would be my pick i'm still reeling
from last season you know it's just so
much fun when they when they surprise me
i don't want to put a wish lit a wish
list together and get uh and get
disappointed so
i'm uh i'm just rolling with the punches
i i am getting wrapped so very lastly
abigail spencer we know that she's in
the premiere episode
what all should we expect
in the season premiere it looks like a
massive crossover
pretty explosive uh episode the phoenix
fair is happening in seattle we should
probably mention that there's a big fair
happening in seattle
um grace is short-staffed
um
and so there's there's i mean i feel
like there's a little bit of everything
in the premiere i feel like we're our
writers are amazing they're able to fit
everything in a little bit of drama a
little bit of relationships
um
a lot of meredith meredith cool
interesting things are happening in the
premiere i can think i can tell you this
amelia and link
come together in the first episode
working together on a medical case and
they have to put all of their personal
stuff behind them meanwhile
uh there's a lot of personal stuff
happening in front of them with the
patients that's kind of like reflecting
what's going on with them so it's like
they're not talking about it but the
patients are talking about it right so
yeah it's a very funny dynamic yeah i
love about gray's right yeah it's what
we do best